what j.j brooms did was star wars with
that with the force awakens he
essentially rebooted star wars without
rebooting star wars
houston what are your thoughts on
hollywood reboots what are we doing
wrong what are we doing right
i think reboots
in general
i yeah i'm not a i'm not a huge fan of
them i i think you know i
in in in large respect you know
people talk about you know they ruin my
childhood and things like that like we
have nostalgia about you know the things
that we loved before uh but at the same
time
reboots
reintroduce
the story to a new generation that that
wouldn't necessarily go back and watch
an older film and we have to understand
that reality of it if you know i um you
know i uh i loved ghostbusters uh when i
was a kid uh but i tried to show
ghostbusters to my little girl and it
just wasn't jiving with her like she you
know it's different filmmaking different
storytelling styles in different eras
right i mean even even with with star
wars uh you know the original star wars
she's she just thinks it's like a weird
old movie uh because the filmmaking's so
different now right and so she likes the
new star wars movies more than the old
star wars movies uh when i think you
know artistically the old star
wars movies were were better uh but but
with reboots i think
you know
is there a generation of kids that will
actually go back and watch the old 21
jump street series probably not
should they yeah of course they should
of course yeah but will they
probably not
and so that means there's going to be a
generation of kids that don't know
the the 21 jump street story and so
rebooting 21 jump street in a different
way reintroduces the ip to a new
generation so
in that regard i i'm i'm i'm down with
it i like it uh i think though what's
better is let's figure out how to do
a soft reboot but still extend the story
i think that's the sweet spot and you
really look to see you know something
like um uh what jj brooms did with star
wars with that with the force awakens he
essentially rebooted star wars without
rebooting star wars he he technically
told the new story but if you look at
the way that movie
was structured and the story and the
characters it was basically a soft
reboot of star wars for people that
haven't seen star wars
and uh it basically retold a new hope
just in a very new and different way and
uh and but at the same time for legacy
fans it still extended the story for us
so technically it was new stories new
story for us didn't ruin our childhood
because they weren't you know just
wiping away the old and re-establishing
the new and that's what fans don't like
about reboots they're saying the thing
that we love before is now no more we're
erasing that from canon and we're we're
we're now creating this new thing and
we're going to start here comic book
fans uh uh
it's it's referred to as a renumbering
when they they'll say you know this
there's superman 731 issue 731 they'll
say we're going to renumber we're going
to start over number one which means
we're going to wipe out the cannon of
all the old stuff that's always painful
for fans to do that but that's
essentially what reboots
do they say the old hawaii 5.0 is no
longer now it's the new hawaii 5.0 and
the fans the old old
get surly about that because they're
precious and there's nostalgia and
there's memories attached to it and
things like that even though you know
technically is the new stuff better
because there's better filmmaking
techniques and better technology
maybe probably you know that's that's
that's a subjective call right but
but i think the sweet spot is let's
figure out how to do soft reboot reboots
that ex that extend for legacy audience
but but create a new entry point in for
a new audience find that that
intersection if the uh you look at what
they're doing with the ghostbusters and
uh my little girl didn't like the old
the old ghostbusters um then uh you know
the female ghostbusters that uh you know
when that dropped that just didn't work
because ghostbusters fans
rejected it
because they're saying wait a minute
like those aren't my ghostbusters i love
dan aykroyd and i love you know i i i
love my ghostbusters
where's egon and all that like that's
the kind of nerdy stuff that that fans
get into now you know there are there's
also the layer of you know the the
misogynistic these are women and we
didn't like that there's that whole sort
of political angle to it but i think a
large degree
legacy ghostbusters fans just just
didn't like their their ghostbusters
being deleted for new ghostbusters i
think if they were if it was all men it
probably wouldn't have worked either
right may have been
a different commentary around it listen
and and you know of course i'm not
denying the fact that there were people
that were just misogynistic jerks about
the whole thing of course there was that
i don't know if that was the bulk of it
i think it just wouldn't work regardless
because that movie is so precious to so
many people uh
that but now
it's a whole different conversation with
the new ghostbusters movies that's
coming out which effectively is a is a
reboot of ghostbusters for people who
have never seen ghostbusters but it
still extends ghostbusters for people
that have seen ghostbusters the legacy
audience right and so you you have to
try to find that sweet spot i think of
of how do we extend and continue
rather than
stop delete and then restart right and
so that's i think that's what we
that i think is a better way forward
than just the the the hard reboot um and
and maybe there's there's a different
term uh for it but but i think you know
from a from a you can't
you have to you have to get a buy-in
from a legacy audience especially
something like iconic iconic like like
uh like ghostbusters right uh that has a
community a fan community around it
maybe there wasn't a fan community
around hawaii 5-0 or maybe maybe there
was maybe there was i'm not sure but uh
but
things that have actual fan community
around it
i think i really feel like you have to
you have to you have to continue rather
than just restart and you know delete
everything that that's old they're
they're uh uh uh
facing this with the reboot of the
pirates of the caribbean franchise and
uh which is crazy they're already
talking about rebooting pirates of the
caribbean they feel like it was just out
five minutes ago but uh but there it's
going to be a hard reboot
which means they're just going to start
over and start telling different stories
with a new jack sparrow and and and and
that's
that's that for all the fans that love
johnny depp as jack sparrow and all
those old movies
then then that's going to be a hard
tough pill to swallow to say
all this stuff that i love doesn't count
anymore and because now it's this new
thing and there's going to be a division
in the fandom you can't divide fandom
like that and expect to be a success and
so uh so so yeah i'm not ideal ideolo
ideologically against
reboots of like all reboots are terrible
uh i think some are smart and some
reintroduce
fans to new stuff like what if they
would i ever want them to reboot the
princess bride
no
right
but do do kids today go back and watch
the princess bride will they ever maybe
i don't know like that's the that's
that's the calculation right but but i
think it would be better to do
the princess bride
now so many years later that extends the
original but still is a soft entry point
for new fans but still serves the legacy
audience how do we how do we find that
balance i'm not saying it's easy
jj abrams did it with force awakens did
it really well uh but uh and i think the
ghostbusters is doing that really well
uh but it's not easy it's a balancing
act but i feel like in today's
fandom-driven market you've got to find
that balance